[Musique]
on va jouer à qui va se la prendre sur
le front du coin mais sartre sur le
front vous allez vous mettre là je
posais des questions sur la télé à
ophélie money si elle répondait a pas de
problème si elle n'est pas mal
vous devrez vous mettre ici tourner la
manivelle comme ceux ci et à un moment
la tarte va arriver mais parfois elle
n'a elle pas c'est comme la roulette
russe
voyez ou pas oui ça va ça va le faucon
qu'est ce que je vous appelle à l'arrêt
des attaques comme d'habitude allez on
va raser tout ça d'accord et on va
égaliser sur les côtés jean-pierre faut
bien mettre votre ton mouton ici parce
que sinon ça sera pas bon vous inquiétez
pas chopper un moment vous pouvez dire
sur cette question je prends le joker
cyril d'accord ou bien le joker un des
chroniqueurs
attention voici les questions s'ils ne
répondent pas bien si je vous aime quand
même si les cm1 qui va se la prendre sur
le front c'est tout de suite avec
ophélie meunier et jean pierre foucault
[Musique]
vous devez valider votre réponse par sur
la vie de tata rachel syrie quel est le
slogan de la chaîne numéro 23 à 1
tolérance zéro b la diversité avant tout
c'est voir la vie autrement ou des 23
téléspectateurs pas un de plus r d
alors j'ai dit un truc non j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment pas envie vous mangez les
chantiers la diversité avant tout
répondre à ce besoin ladite ag c'est
plus dans la vie tu t'arraches l on voit
là et elle s'en souvient marie la
diversité avant tout malheureusement la
bonne réponse c'est un tolérance zéro de
la chaîne numéro 23
jean-pierre un petit tour de manivelle
pour voir si la tarte part c'est bon
c'est bon
quel est le véritable nom de mac lesggy
vous savez ce présentateur 2e égale m6
est-ce que c'est olivier lesgourgues
raciale ruim gil marin j ou bien grichka
bogdanoff
non parce qu'elle avait pascal rioult
nature je valide
vous validez d'accord jean-pierre vous
pouvez prendre
vous aurez de joker mois et un
producteur ce que vous faites tourner ou
ce qu'on prenait tout de suite un joker
de tournai fait tourner
au monde entier
je vous laisse vous avez du pétrole
jean-pierre suis désolé vous chantez air
france porte mais on fait les me
répondait pas à bosser
jean-pierre sabah non vous n'êtes pas si
ce n'est pas taillé j'aurai deux mois
dire oui à la paire sera dûment briefés
sur le jeu oui j'aurais deux mois dire
sur la personne qui m'a briefé sur le
jeu car comme ici rien n'est truc et il
m'a dit ne t'inquiète pas si au
troisième clip que ça sort
[Musique]